Just Cause 3 makes no apologies for it's
outrageous nature it's a power fantasy
in every sense of the phrase placing you
in a world ripe with destructible
environments and giving you instruments
with which to destroy them
there are intermittent technical
problems and scripted moments to track
from the freedom found elsewhere but in
the end Just Cause 3 presents a
spectacular sandbox experience the plot
revolves around returning protagonist
Rico Rodriguez who's arrived in the
fictional Republic of Medici during the
height of a military dictatorship the
story here is forgettable but it
delivers an effective invitation dozens
of military installations cover the
world map and it's your job to blow them
up for the rebel forces Rodriguez
himself is a mash-up of masculine action
stars and comic book characters so it
makes sense that I often feel like a
superhero in his shoes by supplying us
with a wingsuit parachute and grappling
hook Just Cause 3 gives us not just
effective means of transportation but
also a smooth nuanced traversal system
there is a steep learning curve but with
practice I was leaping from helicopters
gliding through enemy bases and floating
over farmland with ease I actually felt
like a hero learning his new skill set
it's as if Avalanche Studios combined
Batman spider-man and The Punisher and
thrust its creation into a vivid
Mediterranean landscape what follows is
a kaleidoscope of spectacle and scale
helicopters dot the sky chain explosions
cover the screen in a world teetering
toward total destruction Just Cause 3
grants us the tools to push it over the
edge I have the traditional grenades
remote mines and numerous land air and
sea vehicles on call but then there's
the tether this grappling hook
modification attaches to separate
objects and through tension can pull
them toward each other with hilarious
results I reeled enemies toward
explosive barrels collapse watchtowers
and pulled attack helicopters into a
fiery end
it's a testament to this game's
creativity that guns were often my last
resort like Olive Just Cause threes best
moments the tether encourages
experimentation rather than thoughtless
reaction and as the hours passed the
destruction stayed fresh the small
mechanic encapsulate what makes Just
Cause 3 so fun it leads to numerous
possibilities and even now after 30
hours in this idyllic sandbox I'm sure I
haven't seen them all and almost every
activity in Just Cause threes world is
worth doing as you liberate new
provinces from enemy hands
challenges will pop up across the map
these include vehicle races machine guns
score contests and wingsuit dives and by
completing these you'll unlock new gear
mods which further change the function
of certain items while some of these are
miners such as increased grenade
capacity or a nitrous boost for vehicles
others reveal dynamic new ways to
experiment in Just Cause threes world
take the booster mod for remote mines
for example whereas previous versions of
the device just detonated at a chosen
time this modification sends objects
careening into distant structures before
exploding I use this on cars numerous
times creating two-ton bombs that flew
toward enemy fuel tanks after I have
dough from the driver's seat and this is
only one of the many uses I discovered
with just this one small upgrade this
cascading structure is what makes Just
Cause 3 so great there's a cadence to
how you approach its world outpost
liberation leads to challenges which
lead to gear mods which lead to even
further experimentation and more often
than not each tier of this formula is
entertaining in itself Just Cause 3
excels because it adds variety to the
equation throughout making destruction
and mayhem entertaining far past the
early hours however Just Cause 3 does
deviate from its open-world freedom at
times and what it does it falters the
scripted story missions progress the
plot but the actual gameplay involved is
repetitive at best and broken at worst
the vast majority of these tasks are
escort missions in which you defend a
plane or boat or caravan of jeeps
protecting another character can be
tiresome to begin with but when their
behavior is unpredictable and often
unintelligent I restarted checkpoints
far more than felt fair just cos 3 is
also filled with some bugs and other
rough edges my parachute sometimes
closed at random and AI behavior made
several story objectives impossible
and for a game that places death front
and center it was often inconsistent
with whether I should die or not I'm
happy just cause 3 is lenient with its
falling damage considering I'm in the
sky more often than not when I survived
a 500-foot fall at one point only to die
from a shorter one soon thereafter these
mishaps would be easy to overlook if
they didn't disrupt an otherwise fluid
experience too often when Just Cause 3
is consistent however it's a stunning
display of cause and effect but there's
a more thoughtful undercurrent as well
despite the explosions and instant
gratification throughout Just Cause 3
also encourages experimentation and
foresight and the results are as
rewarding as they are entertaining